I want to take up in volume 12, March the 14, 1920. The martyrdom of love surpasses in an
almost infinite way all other martyrdoms together.
Weza said my state is even more painful, and while I was swimming in the immense sea of the
privations of my sweet Jesus, of my life, of my all, I couldn't help lamenting and also
speaking some nonsense. So I want to give you Sam 73 verses 25 to 26. Jesus said,
Jesus moved in her interior, which of course is Luke 17 21, the kingdom of God is within you,
and one Corinthians 3 16, you are the temple of the living God and the spirit of God dwells in you.
Jesus said, my daughter, you are the hardest martyrdom, the crudest pain of my heart,
and every time I see you moan and petrified by the pain of my privation, my martyrdom becomes
more bitter. And the spasm is such that I am forced to sigh, and moaning, I say, oh man,
how much you have cost me. You formed my martyrdom to my humanity, which taken by folly of love for
you, took upon itself all your pains, and you continue to form the martyrdom of the one who
taken by love for me, and for you, has offered herself as a victim for me, and for your sake.
So my martyrdom is continuous, even more, I feel it more vividly because it is the
martyrdom of one who loves me, and the martyrdom of love surpasses in an almost infinite way
all other martyrdoms together. So here we have Louisa's martyrdom of the heart compared to
Jesus' martyrdom, and Jesus' martyrdom was due to his love for humanity, and taking all of humanity's
trials and pains and burdens upon himself, and he did it out of love for us. And now,
Louisa is doing the same thing out of love for Jesus and for us, and so since Jesus and Louisa
are united together in the highest possible union in the divine will, of course, he feels it,
and he says that through Louisa, his own martyrdom continues, and he says that the martyrdom of love
surpasses infinitely all other martyrdoms put together. One of the reasons for that is that
goes on and on and on, moment by moment, day by day, whereas if someone offers,
someone's life is taken from them in martyrdom, then it lasts only a short time and it's all over.
But this martyrdom is on a daily, hourly, minutely basis.
Then drawing his mouth close to the ear of my heart, I don't understand that expression how
the heart could have an ear, but never mind. He said, "My daughter, my daughter,
only your Jesus can understand you and sympathize with you because I feel your martyrdom within mine."
And then he added, "Listen, my daughter, if the chastisement of war, if sorry, with the chastisement
of war, man had humbled himself and come to his senses, other chastisements would not be necessary."
Now the whole idea is to bring down the pride of man and make him turn back to God. So that's
Isaiah chapter 2, verses 9, 11 and 17, that he would come to his senses as the prodigal son
feeding among the pigs, Luke 15, 17. And so I also want to give you Luke 8, 35 to 36.
So if the original chastisements had brought about the fruit that God actually wanted,
which was that the pride of man would be brought low and man would turn to God with humility
and repentance, then other chastisements wouldn't be necessary.
But instead of humbling himself, man has raged even more. Therefore, in order to make man
come to his senses, now notice this time there is insistence and force on the part of the Lord.
In other words, human beings won't do it on their own. They won't accept the hint.
They won't accept the invitation to come back to the Lord. So in order to make man come to his
senses, more terrible chastisements than the war itself are actually needed.
And this will happen, he says, so he's obviously thinking of World War II and all the wars since
and possibly World War III. Therefore, justice is forming voids. That is the space for justice
to act. And therefore, Louisa feels that she's not part of it. Therefore, justice is forming
voids. And if you knew what a void is being formed in my justice, with my not coming to you,
you would tremble, he said. In fact, if I came to you, you would take my justice to yourself
and taking the pains upon yourself, you would feel the voids that man forms with sin.
Have you not done this, he said, for many years? But now, the obstinacy of man, that's your Jeremiah
17 9 to 10. The obstinacy of man renders him unworthy of this great good. Now that obstinacy
is stubborn hardness of heart, which absolutely rejects all the approaches of the Lord.
But now the obstinacy of man renders him unworthy of this great good. And this is why I often deprive
you of myself. In other words, he chooses justice, not the victim soul. And in seeing you
martyred because of me, my pain is so great that I become delirious, I moan, I sigh, and I am forced
to hide my moans from you without even being able to pour them out on you so as not to give you even
more pains. So Jesus is saying that he's not only keeping away from her in order to give justice
its free vent on the human race, but he's also staying away from her out of pure love so as not
to increase her love, her pains, sorry. So, March the 19th, 1920, life in the divine will means
to live without one's own life without personal reflections. But it is the life that embraces all
lives together. Okay, so here we have another wonderful insight into what living in the divine
will actually is. Now you're talking about someone whose will is locked into the divine will.
Louisa said she was lamenting as usual and she says to the Lord you have changed, is it possible
that not even suffering is there for me anymore. Now he has just explained to her that when she's
not suffering, that he is chastising, but she never accepts that. She feels she's not doing what she
was made to do unless she's suffering. She said I alone am not worthy to suffer. It's true that I
surpass everyone in badness, but you she said have pity on me. Do not deny me at least the crumbs
of the great suffering which you abundantly pour. You don't deny to anybody else. My love,
how horrifying my state is, she said have pity on me, have pity. So Jesus moved in her interior,
Luke 1721, and he said my daughter, Cam yourself, otherwise you hurt me. In other words, he's told
her endlessly, but she's not accepting it. Otherwise you hurt me and you open deeper gaseous in my heart.
Do you perhaps want to surpass me? He has told her and volume 12 isn't the only place he has told her,
he has told her in earlier volumes as well, time out of number. He has told her that during the days
of his incarnation, there were certain things that he wasn't allowed to do, that justice had to be
given its freedom to work. He said do you want to surpass me? I too would have wanted to enclose
in me all the pains of creatures. My love towards creatures was so great that I would have wanted
no pain to touch them anymore. But this I couldn't obtain, and I had to submit to the wisdom and
the justice of the father. And this of course is what is being asked of Louisa as well, who while
allowing me to satisfy to a large extent for the pains of creatures, it did not want satisfaction
from me for all the pains. That's very interesting. In other words, divine wisdom and divine justice
demanded that all of us would have to participate in the sufferings that came as a result of our
own sins and the sins of others. We have to participate, we have to grow up.
And this was for the decorum and the balance of divine justice. He said my humanity would have
wanted to suffer so much as to put an end to hell and to put an end to purgatory and to all
scourges. But the divinity didn't want that. And justice said to my love, you wanted the right
of love, and it was granted to you. Now I want the rights of justice as well, because all of the
divine attributes are infinitely equal. So Jesus said, I resigned myself to the wisdom of my father,
John 1431. I could give you many others as well. I saw this wisdom as just, but my moaning humanity
felt the pain of it because of the pains that touched the creatures. Jesus suffered because
they suffered. And he still tells Louisa that with the chastisement, he also suffers as well.
But he resigned himself. In hearing your lament, he said, for not suffering,
I hear the echo of my limits. And I run to sustain your heart and to give you strength,
knowing how hard this pain is, know, however, that this is also the pain of your Jesus.
And he has told her from volume one that he wants her as a perfect replica of himself.
So if he went through it, he wants her to go through it in the measure that a creature can.
And so Louisa said that she resigned herself for love of Jesus, also not to suffer. But the
torment of our heart was even more bitter. The torment of our heart was even more bitter.
And many things wandered through her mind, especially on what he had told her about the divine volition.
I seemed not to see in me the effects of his word. Now, this is a very, very important point
because we are doing our acts in the divine will. We are reading and studying the text. We are trying
to live this wonderful mission. And yet I'm sure you can join Louisa in saying,
I don't see in me the effects of this teaching. And so it can be a real problem and it can be
a temptation to give up as well. So again, Jesus comes back in the next section to tell us that
the human life must give way to the divine. The divine has to take over. My daughter, Jesus said,
when I asked you whether you would consent to want to live in my divine will, and you accepted,
you said, I say yes, not with my will, but in yours, so that my yes may have all the power and the value
of a yes of the divine volition. That yes still exists and will always exist just as my will always
exists. Therefore, your human life is ended. You signed up for this. Your human life has no more
reason to live. You signed down the dotted line that you wanted the divine life. You can't have both.
So your human will has no more reason to live. And this is why I told you that since all creatures
are in my will, in the name of the whole human family, you can come to lay at the foot of my
throne in a divine manner, the thoughts of all in your mind, to bring me the glory of each thought
in your gaze, in your word, in your action, in the food you take, and even in your sleep,
you can bring me those of all. So your life must embrace everything because the divine will
embraces everything. See, one of the signs by which you will know how far you've got into this living
in the divine will has your thoughts and has your prayers become universal.
And don't you see, Jesus said, that when sometimes oppressed by the weight of my privation,
something escapes you of what you do. And you do not unite all the human family together. I
reprimand you, he says. And if you don't listen to me, afflicted, I say to you, if you don't want
to follow me, I'll do it by myself. Life in my will means to live without one's own life.
Now let me repeat that. Life in the divine will means to live without one's own. Let's add the word
human life. You've given up the human for the divine. It's to live without personal reflections,
what's in it for me? Where am I in this? Where am I going? How is this benefiting me? Blah, blah,
blah. All that has got to be deleted. But it is the life that embraces all lives together.
Your only interest is in the glory of God and the salvation of souls.
Very good discernment there. And we've had that a number of times now in recent messages.
So March the 23rd, 1920, the soul wants hiddenness and Jesus wants her as light. So instead of saying
the soul there, put Louisa, Louisa wants to be completely hidden. But the Lord has put her as a
lamp on a lampstand. And she needs to be seen by the whole church because he's initiating a new era
of divine holiness through her. So Louisa was saying to Jesus, I would like to hide myself to
the point of disappearing from everyone. And so that everyone would forget about me as if I no longer
existed on the earth, how heavy it is for me having to deal with people. I feel all the necessity of
a profound silence. Well, the closer people get to God, the greater is the need for that profound
silence. And Jesus moving in her interior said, you want to hide yourself and I want you as a
candelabra, a lamp on a lampstand. And it must give light. Now that's Matthew 514 to 16, Matthew 1343.
This lampstand, or a candelabra, I think he's thinking of the seven branch candlesticks
before the Holy of Holies in the temple, the menorah. So this menorah will be lit by the
reflections of my eternal light. So a priest used to light the seven lamps in front of the
Holy of Holies every day in the temple, representing the seven is perfection,
representing all the perfections of God. And he said, no, the lamp that you are, the candelabra,
the menorah that you are, will be lit by the reflections of my eternal light. Because everything,
once you're in the divine will, everything comes from him. So if you want to hide,
you do not hide yourself, you hide me and you hide my light and you hide my word.
Now he's told us perfectly clearly in the gospel that we're not to hide the word,
we're not to put it under a bushel. So that's Matthew 515, Mark 421, and Luke 1133.
So Louisa said that after this she continued to pray and she found herself outside of herself
together with Jesus, but she was small and he was great. And Jesus said, my daughter stretch
yourself so as to equal me. How can a tiny speck of dust stretch itself to equal the divine?
It can only be done in the divine will and through the divine will with the power of the divine will,
who can do anything because nothing is impossible with God. And Jesus placed his hands within
mind, you see the power is coming from him, and he repeated to me, stretch yourself, stretch yourself.
That means you want to do it. I tried and I felt like a spring, she said, such that if I wanted
to stretch, I got longer. If not, I remain small. In other words, notice that she has to use her free
will to agree with the Lord, your free will is always free. Even when you're completely committed
to him and totally consecrated to his divine will, he gave you free will, he will never take it back.
It's the opposite of that with people who get involved in the occult and Satanism.
As soon as Satan gets a grip on a person's will, he enslaves them and they're no longer free
to use their free will. So, Louisa said, I easily stretched myself and I leaned my head upon Jesus's
shoulders. So she started out very small, like a little child, and now she's tall, like an adult.
And he continued to keep his hands within mind. At the contact of his most holy hands, I was reminded
of the wounds of Jesus. And I said to him, my love, you want me to equal you? Why don't you give me
your pains? Give them to me and don't deny them to me. And Jesus looked at me and pressed me
tightly to his heart as if he wanted to tell me many things, but he disappeared instead. And
Louisa came back to herself. So, if Jesus has given her that exercise about stretching,
then as we go on in the messages, you're going to find out why.
So, April the third 1920, all the will of God in creating man was that he would do his will in
everything in order to develop his life. So, let's put that into simple English. God's will in
creating man was that we would do his will and that we would have his life in us.
So, Jesus said to Louisa, my daughter, all my will are the only thing I ever wanted.
In creating man was that he would do my will in everything. And as he would gradually continue
to do this will of mine, I would come to complete my life in him in such a way that after repeated
jacks done in my will, forming my life in him, I would come to him and finding him similar to me,
the sun of my life, finding the sun of my life that he had formed in his own soul would absorb him
into me. And as they would be transformed together, these two suns would become one.
I would bring him into the delights of heaven. Now, what Jesus has said here is the main topic of
the entire Bible. Starting in Genesis, the only thing that God ever asked of man was that we would
do his will. And it's summarized in Micah 6, 8. This is what the Lord asked of you, only this
that you would act justly, that you would love tenderly and that you would walk humbly with your
God. He didn't ask much, but fallen human nature is such that the moment you put up a prohibition
about something, it's the only thing we want. If you put up a no entry sign into a place,
everybody wants to go in and find out why there's no entry. If you've done any babysitting
and the mother has the foolishness to say, don't touch the biscuits before she goes out,
then the only topic of the evening is biscuits. If I've been prohibited from doing something,
then my rebellious, unredeemed will wants that. Don't eat the apple you found in Genesis chapter
3. What did Eve do? She found it very desirable. She gave herself all kinds of reasons and she
rationalized the thing the Lord tells us not to do and she decided, yeah, she'd have it. No matter
what the consequences were. And so what God intended was that we would gradually enter more and more
and more and more deeply into surrendering to His will, that we wouldn't just sort of do it on the
outside. We wouldn't just resign, we would actually embrace it. I think it was St. Therese of Lesus
who said to the Lord, I want what you want for me. So there's the human will at its best. I want
what you want for me. And then as we would come deeper and deeper doing our acts in the divine will,
then Jesus says that the Sun of His life would be formed more and more in us and He would come
and dwell in us. We would become the place or the locus where He would reign on the earth. He would
form His throne in us. Now by the creature not doing my will, Jesus said, or if she does it now
and then she doesn't, my will is halved by the human life and the divine life cannot be completed
in her. It is obscured by the human acts and does not receive abundant fruit to give a development
that would be sufficient in order to form a life. Therefore the soul is in continuous opposition
to the purpose of her creation. But alas how many there are who by living a life of sin and of
passions form within themselves the diabolical life instead. Okay, so if doing God's will and
entering more and more deeply and surrendering to the Lord and doing all our acts in the divine will
forms the throne of Christ on earth. Of course somebody indulging in sin and felt and surrendering
more and more to this spiritual leprosy. Of course they're forming the throne of Satan on the earth
two entirely different kingdoms. Just a tiny little reflection on Jesus saying
earlier he said, "When I would come and find the sun of my life in him,
I'd find him similar to me," he said, "the sun of my life, finding the sun of my life in the soul,
would absorb him into me." Well he keeps on telling us that there's a whole universe inside of us,
parallel to the universe outside of us. Look at some of your astronomy programs and if you see two
galacties merging they have an enormous amount of light separately in all the
periods of stars that they have but when they actually merge they emit tons of light and heat
and energy that's called life. Light, heat and energy is what we call life. They emit absolutely
massive amounts of life and so in these writings Jesus is telling us that when we surrender finally
to the divine will and the divine will can absorb us into himself and we can possess God
that the amount of light and grace and life that will come out of us is only massive.
So April the 15th, 1920, the cause of the pains of Jesus.
Louisa said I was lamenting to my sweet Jesus about my painful state saying to him, "Tell me
my love, where are you? Which way did you go so that I may follow you? Let me see the marks of your
steps so that step by step with certainty I may find you. I had Jesus without you. I can endure
no more. For though you are far away I send you my kisses. I kiss that hand which no longer embraces
me. I kiss that mouth which no longer speaks to me. I kiss that face which I no longer see.
I kiss those feet which no longer walk towards me but turn their steps somewhere else.
Jesus how sad is my state. How cruel this is. Please end the waiting for me."
So this is the bride looking for her her beloved and you'll find it in the song of songs chapter
five verse six. And also I want to give you one Peter one eight to nine where Saint Peter tells
the Christians in the early church that even though you don't see him you love him and without
loving him you'll even experience a joy so glorious that it's unbelievable.
And so Jesus came he moved in her interior where he is residing as in his own temple
and he said my daughter cam yourself for one who lives in my will all points are sure ways
in order to find me. In other words you can find me anywhere. I am everywhere. The Sam 139
where can I go from your spirit? Where can I flee from your face? If I go to the heavens you are there
if I go to the depths of shame you are there. If I find myself in darkness darkness is not dark
to you the night is as bright as the day. So he said at all points no matter what your
experience is whether it's darkness or light cold or heat whatever it is sickness or health
you can find me. My will finds everything. Whatever way she might take there's no fear
that she won't find me. And my daughter I feel your painful state in my we would say my sacred heart.
I find the current of pain that passed between me and my mother being repeated
that is between Louisa and him because after all blessed mother lived in the divine will
and lived at the height of the divine will the summit and therefore the
current of connection between Jesus and herself is beyond our ability to understand.
So he said the pain that passed between them that he can feel it coming through Louisa as well.
She was crucified because of my pains he said I was crucified because of hers.
"What was the cause of all this?" he said it was the love of souls.
"For love of them my dear mother bore all my pains and even my death
and I for love of souls bore all her pains to the point of depriving her of me.
Oh how much it costs my love and her maternal love to deprive my inseparable mother of me
but the love of souls triumphed over everything. Now he's given he's given Louisa a very important
way of surviving the deprivation and that is that love of souls must triumph
and it must triumph over everything her pain her longing her need for this or that or the other
and therefore she must be ready to put up with anything for the sake of saving souls.
And he gives her our blessed mother as her model and Louisa loved being close to our blessed mother
and following her and working with her as much as possible. So then he comes to Louisa.
Now your state of victim to which you submitted yourself you go back to volume one
where she willingly offered herself to the Lord as a victim soul to intercede and save as many
souls as possible and to make reparation for the church and the world and he said
the reason why you did it was love of souls and for love of them you accepted all the pains
that have unfolded in your life. That's going back the last 12 volumes.
The cause has of all of this has been souls and the sad times that are coming that's
obviously in World War II and III and everything in between. He said because of which my divine
justice prevents me from being with you in a familiar way in order to let more favorable times
flow rather than stormy and keep you on the earth. So two Corinthians five, one to ten.
Everything is because of souls. So this is her big motive now for accepting the deprivation
which she says she has no suffering but she has the deprivation which is the deepest suffering
if she offers that in union with blessed mothers a deprivation and Jesus is a deprivation because
after all he experienced it on the cross as well to gain his infinite merits and in the divine will
it will have an absolutely super massive response in terms of saving souls.
So he said the cause has been souls and the sad times that are coming because of which the
divine justice prevents me from being more familiar with you in order to let more favorable times flow
rather than stormy and keep you upon the earth. It's because of souls. If it were not for love
of them your exile would be ended. In other words Jesus would have long since taken her to heaven
and you would not have the pain of seeing yourself without me nor would I have the pain of
seeing you so tormented because of my privation. Therefore have patience and let it be that also
in you the love of souls may triumph to the end and so he gives her the motivation now
so that we're dealing with the heroic love of the neighbor yet you would suffer anything.
There's no limit to the price that you would suffer in order to save them.
Now her love is like Jesus' love. When you look at John 59
Jesus says as the Father has loved me so I love you. Now the Father loved Jesus
infinitely, absolutely, unconditionally, eternally knowing everything about his Son.
And Jesus said that's the way I love you that's absolutely eternally, unconditionally
knowing everything about you. And he said and that's the way you are to love one another.
So this absolute eternal, unconditional love knowing everything about the other.
Now the thing we know about the souls we're trying to save is their sin and their degradation and
their lack of wisdom and lack of life and blah blah blah and the fact that they're heading straight
for hell if nobody turns them back. But knowing all that that you would pay any price to save them.
Now you've got heroism in love. So May the first 1920 the sanctity of one who lives in the divine
will is the continuous glory be and one who lives up high in the divine will must bear the pains of
those who are living down below in their own will. So Louisa continues my misery makes itself felt
more and in my interior I was saying my Jesus what life is mine and he without giving me any time
immediately answered my daughter for one who lives in my will her sanctity has only one point.
It is the continuous glory be to the Father followed by as it was in the beginning is now
and ever shall be. So here we've just dealt with the fact that you will suffer anything to save
souls but the other side of the coin is that you live entirely for the glory of God. So you're
actually living the life of heaven on earth. There's nothing which does not give glory to God
complete and everything always stable always the same always queen without ever changing. So
if you live in the divine will there's nothing that won't give glory to God. If you're in the
divine will you will be giving glory to God and therefore your acts will be complete and everything
you will be stable in your relationship with God. You'll always be the same you'll always be the
queen you'll be on top without ever changing. So this wonderful stability is there and Jesus
says that this sanctity in the divine will is not subject to setbacks and to losses it will always
reign and so its foundation is the glory be its prerogative as it was in the beginning so Romans
5 17. But Louisa continued to lament about his privations and also the withdrawal of suffering
and Jesus came out from within her interior and leaning his head on her shoulder all afflicted
he spoke to her and he speaks to her about the greatness of the call in the divine will.
"My daughter," he said, "one who lives in my will lives up high." Now that's the position
of the eagle and there are a number of texts in the Bible speaking about the greatness of the eagle
and one of them is in Proverbs chapter 30 and it says there are three things I don't understand
four indeed I don't understand four indeed I don't grasp and it is the way of the eagle in the sky
is the first one and that's the mystery of our high calling in God. The second one is the way of
the snake over the rock and that's the mystery of the enmity between Satan and Christ Christ is the
rock of our salvation. The third one is the way of the ship in mid-ocean and that's the mystery of
the church going through the waters of history the mystery of its survival and the fourth one is
the way of a man with the girl and that's the mystery of the love between Christ and every single soul
it's a bridal mystery it's a spiritual marriage mystery how he loves each soul as if nobody else
existed. So for one who is living in the divine will they must live up high in that great mystery
of the eagle who lives at the tops of the mountains and keeps away from all the fuss and the nonsense
down on ground level but the eagle has extraordinary sight and from a very great height it can actually
see fish in the ocean and make an absolutely death-defying dive into the ocean to get the fish
and it comes up right back to where it arrived from right at the top of the mountain.
When the eagle decides that it wants to go places it doesn't use its own energy instead of that
it waits for the the thermals and depending on the direction the wind is going it will fly on the
wings of the wind and not use its own energy at all or very little of it and so you look up and
you see it soaring in the heavens and that's because it's sitting on the thermals the most
wonderful way and it's a very wonderful image of us completely surrendered to the Lord and allowing
him to guide us and to do everything in us with us and through us. So my daughter one who lives
in my will lives up high and the one who lives up high can look down below because you see other
birds are at a much much lower level than the eagle and they you can look with more clarity
because the eagle has very wonderful eyesight and must take part in the decisions in the afflictions
and in everything that befits the people who live up high so if that is your calling you have got to
do everything that eagles are supposed to do you've got to carry out their office don't you see this
in the world he said sometimes father and mother and sometimes also an elder child is capable of
taking part in decisions and in the sorrows of the parents while they are under the nightmare of
sorrowful pains uncertainties and treagues and losses the other children know nothing about it
and rather they let them go and play and continue the course of ordinary family life not wanting to
imbit her their tender lives without a useful purpose for them and for the parents it's a very
simple wonderful image you're given that the parents and sometimes the eldest child will
form a group that will make all the decisions and the younger ones are allowed to have their
on solid untouched childhoods in a very wonderful way and so the lord gets people living in the
divine will to understand the needs of souls and to take decisions about
making reparation for them and substituting further men suffering further men all the rest of it
but these souls go gaily on and they don't realize anybody's interested in them they will be utterly
amazed and shocked when they arrive in heaven and discover i am here because of somebody else
because somebody else paid a great price that's like saying that a child
gets some big opportunity for education because an uncle or an aunt or somebody has actually paid
the fees the parents couldn't pay it so somebody else pays the fees somebody who isn't as closely
related as the immediate family and jesus said the same thing happens in the order of grace
one who is little and still growing lives down below
so when you're dealing with the divine will there are three levels that we need to remember
the lowest level is where the world is at where people are they may have a religion but they don't
really have faith not real faith in a personal relationship with god and many of them have
don't really bother about religion and they're worldly and they're getting on with sort of
minding themselves and their own interests and so on and they're living down below in their own
will and therefore there will always be purges necessary for them and there will always have to be
the necessary means in order to make them grow in sanctity so sajana the cross tells us that
god will use the ordinary tribulations of every day to get them to grow it would be as if one
wanted to talk about business intrigues pains to the little ones in the family they would be stunned
without understanding anything but one who lives in my will living high up must bear the pains of
those who live down below see there's the position that louisa is in suffering for people she doesn't
know the one who lives up high must see their dangers must help them and take such serious
decisions as to make one tremble while they remain tranquil and even unaware
so jesus made all these decisions for us because he was our elder brother and now at the beginning
of the new era of the new holiness we have louisa as an elder sister
the ones who will take decisions for the little ones therefore calm yourself he said and in my
will we that is together will live life in common you and me and i and you as john 14 20 to 21
and together with me you will take part in the pains of the human family
so louisa the elder sister takes part with jesus the elder brother in saving the little ones
you will watch over the great storms which will arise again the great storms are the
wars and the conflicts and all the rest of it and just as the apostles called upon jesus to calm
the storms so souls without even realizing it will be relying on louisa to pray them through the storms
and while they play in the midst of danger you together with me will cry over their misfortune
so here you've got the great responsibility that the ones who live up high take for the ones who
are living down below who are not even aware of the danger that they're in so let's take me the 15th
1920 the divine will forms the complete crucifixion of the soul this is the bit about divine will
the people find difficult louisa was lamenting to jesus where are your promises she said no more
cross no more lightness to you everything is vanished and there's nothing left for me to cry
over except my sorrowful end so i want to give you sam 73 verses 25 to 26 so jesus said to her
my daughter my crucifixion was complete that means nothing left out and you know why
because it was done in the eternal will of my father in this will the cross became so long and
so wide as to embrace all centuries and penetration to every heart past present and future
in such a way that i remained crucified in the heart of each person there's something we really
need to look at and that is that the crucifixion isn't just something that happened in jerusalem
it's happening as we know in the mystery of the holy eucharist all the time jesus has explained
that endlessly to us but it's also happening in the mystery of each life in every heart
this divine will put nails through all of my interior into my desires into my affections
into my heartbeats i can say that i did not have a life of my own but the life of the eternal will
which enclosed all creatures in me and which wanted me to answer for everything so there's the one
living up high answering for the ones living down below not even understanding the dangers they're in
my crucifixion could never have been complete or so extended as to embrace all if the eternal
volition had not been the actor now we've dealt with this before that if the divine will had not
actually done this interior passion in jesus no way could human beings give him enough suffering
to actually save us i want that in you also the crucifixion will be complete and extended to all
so she's to be an image of him this is the reason for the continuous call into my will
it's the reason for the spurs to bring the whole human family before the supreme majesty
and to admit in the name of all the acts which they don't do
the oblivion of yourself the lack of self-reflections are nothing other than the nails
which my divine will has put into you my will does not know how to do incomplete and small things
and forming a circle around the soul it the divine will wants the soul within itself
so i want to give you Philippians one six that the lord will complete the work he begins in us
so my will wants the soul within itself and extending her within the whole sphere of the
divine volition it places on her the seal of its completion that's your Philippians one six
my will empties the interior of the creature of all that is human that's the bit where initially
we find it rather difficult and my will places in the soul all that is divine so just looking at
that sentence alone you'll know where you're at in this journey and in order to be more sure
the divine will keep sealing all of the soul's interior with as many nails for as many human acts
as can have life in the creature substituting them with as many divine acts in this way it forms
in her the true crucifixion not for a time but for her entire life
and in case you really balk at that i want to give you hebrews twelve two that's the same for us
as it was with jesus that for the joy that was said before him he endured the cross despising the
shame and for the joy of living in the divine will and being the throne of god on earth and letting
him do what he wants to do let us endure whatever comes for love of him and for love of souls
i want to stop there